[Music]
so after the recent release of the
outriders demo
we've now had the chance to have a small
taste of what the game has to offer
now i'll be the first to admit my
expectations were pretty low
especially when you consider the games
that have been released over the last
couple of years
but still i was cautiously optimistic
however after trying this both co-op and
single player
and putting quite a few hours into it i
was actually surprised
though this game is certainly no game of
the year not by a long shot
what it does do it does well this
obviously isn't my usual style of video
but
i fancied mixing things up a bit and for
those who care i'll be giving my
thoughts around outriders
and what we've seen so far i won't just
be talking about the gameplay
but also my particular area of interest
the story
but let's face it even the best story in
the world needs some decent gameplay in
order to keep you going
so let's start with that
it's very much like gears of war the
division and destiny got together
had some sort of weird love triangle and
gave birth to a game called outriders
inspiration has clearly been taken from
each of these titles
from the movement and cover system all
the way up to the skills in combat
you'll notice similarities
immediately upon starting the game i
felt the influence of the gears of war
movement system
except this was a little different in a
number of these rpg cover shooters
there is a certain responsiveness that
is applied to the character models
that can differ between class types lack
of this responsiveness
gives the player a feeling of weight
behind the model where the more agile
classes feel lighter
and faster but in outriders this doesn't
seem to apply at all
in fact it's almost too responsive in
some situations though some of this
could be sorted in the settings
the models feel light on their feet and
quick to react which is good because the
pace of the game is considerably more
aggressive than other titles
enemies are quick to advance and
reposition themselves behind cover
forcing the player to react quickly i
actually quite enjoyed this controlled
chaos style of play
but for those of you who enjoy a slower
more tactical combat system
may struggle a bit however i did feel
that more often than not
the combat was over just as fast as it
started
one part of the movement that i really
couldn't get behind was the cover system
this was horrible when it worked it was
okay but a little clunky
however while in combat this was
probably the number one thing that
killed me
it never seemed to work when i needed it
to unless there are some major changes
to avoid the frustration and rage
inducing moments that i experienced
i'd recommend avoiding it altogether
being such an aggressive game you
wouldn't expect there to be much room
for ranged weapons
but this wasn't the case in fact snipers
are one of my favorite to run
all of the weapon archetypes feel unique
but other than range
i didn't really notice a large trade-off
between them regarding the kick or
stability
i do have small concerns around certain
weapon types not really being used but
this could just be my particular style
of play kicking in
i couldn't really find anything better
to use than a decent sniper and shotgun
this generally cleared most situations i
came across
weapons do have a feeling of being
somewhat an afterthought though
they work and they do what they're
supposed to but it very much feels like
that they're only there to fill the gaps
while waiting for your skills to come
off cooldown
the loot system is pretty
straightforward as you gain experience
the loot that drops increases in damage
or armor
when getting to the point of rare gear
being dropped attributes will start
being included
and this is where the build diversity
will start to take effect
at this stage from what we've been able
to see the gear doesn't seem to offer
much in the way of variety
mostly just basic buffs and or further
increasing the efficiency of skills
available to each class being played
though some buffs can dramatically
increase the skill output
but admittedly this could change as
we're able to level and progress through
the world tears
regardless of whether using skills
weapons or melee
something the game does do quite well is
fulfilling the power fantasy
you feel like an absolute beast the
explosions
the headshots and even the melee has you
feeling incredibly strong in fact it's
fantastic regardless of class
even with ranged characters it still has
a decent area of effect
and will often produce a status effect
allowing time to put some distance
between yourself
and the enemies
outriders covers the standard rpg class
system with the tank
dps crowd control and the support class
a lot of games have been following this
classic system lately but most end up
feeling exactly the same
with only some minor changes and
differences between them so i was
expecting outriders to be no different
but without writers the classes actually
support and reward playing in the way
that they were intended
for example i started with the trickster
close range
hit and run high damage this sounded
right up my alley
to get the best out of this class you
need to get up close and personal
using your close range weapons you
should be ducking and weaving to kill
enemies as fast as possible
as this is your main defense you need to
be focusing on offense
from here i transitioned to the
devastator tank character
this played similar in the way the close
range kills will grant extra healing
except that the main difference is that
less ducking and weaving is required
the tank's natural ability to absorb
damage helped give extra time to take
down npcs before ducking into cover
for this reason i would consider this
the easiest class for players new to the
next i tried out the technomancer a long
range support class
playing solo i actually found this quite
a challenge but part of it was because
of the two builds i was playing before
this one
but even then when i adjusted to the
more ranged style of play it was still
tricky to keep that constant stream of
life coming in
while the npcs aggressively pushed
towards me however with the boss fights
where there were less npcs around
this build felt more in its element in a
team situation i felt this build was
stronger
the healing the high support damage this
class felt much stronger with a
trickster or devastator in the team
drawing the npc aggro the pyromancer
felt like it played in a similar way
without the bonus life leech on each
close range kill it felt like a class
that is better utilized in a group
although adequate running solo it didn't
feel as though it packed quite the same
punch as the devastator in the trickster
as a crowd control character it's
expected to do exactly that
control large groups of enemies but in a
solo play situation
it can take considerably longer to take
enemies down versus the other class
skills
in saying all of this we've only really
seen the absolute beginnings of what
each of these classes has to offer
by the point of reaching the in-game my
opinion of each could have changed
dramatically depending on how each of
these play styles are influenced through
the large skill tree each class is
available
one thing i would say the skills are
powerful and fun to use
the tricksters space-time anomaly orb is
just awesome
although you could see a few of the
skills across the classes which is
reskinned duplicates
offering slightly different outcomes the
sheer chaos you can create using them
more than makes up for it
it probably goes without saying that
this particular aspect of the game is
quite important to me
not just because i run a youtube channel
that focuses on this but because this is
what fully immerses me into what i'm
playing gameplay is important and all
but if i can't feel some sort of
attachment to what i'm actually doing
i quickly lose motivation obviously i've
already put out a video on the intro to
the story of which i'll link on the
screen now
but what i was trying to gauge from this
demo was how the story was going to be
told
the background leading up to this point
in the story is good although quite
generic
it locks onto a familiar aspect of what
we face in real life today
humanity has screwed up earth and is
forced to explore options
away from their dying home planet now
you may have that person in your life
that's always telling you to read the
book because it's so much better than
the movie
i was never that person i'd much prefer
to sit on my fat ass and have the tv
doing all the thinking for me
but over time i've come to the
realization that when it comes to most
video games that this is very much the
case
at least for me anyway when too many
cutscenes are given in a game this can
actually drive me away from the story
not just because in most games i feel
like they do a terrible job of it
but because it fills in the gaps that i
would have otherwise come up with on my
own
and in some cases i feel that my
imagination could have come up with a
far more interesting story
i'm not sure if this is actually making
any sense i could probably write a whole
series on this topic alone but long
story short
giving too much detail can actually
remove the immersion for me
the way the characters talk and react
can often be completely different to the
way that i would play out the situation
in my mind
making it difficult for me to relate
unpopular
opinion coming i actually prefer the
silent main character
that some games provide i'm certainly
not so
self-absorbed to think that this is the
way that everyone feels
much like myself with movies a lot if
not most
would prefer to have the story all laid
out in front of them
in saying that i don't think the way
that outriders does it is the best way
yes they're providing more story to a
genre that has struggled with this
aspect
but not everyone is interested in being
delayed by a cinematic
let's say that of all people involved in
the gaming community
30 care about the story or lore of the
games they play
realistically this percentage is
probably much lower
to interrupt the flow of the game to
play a cinematic is one thing
but to continue to do this on the third
fourth and fifth time running through a
particular mission
it becomes a bit much in the outriders
demo i found myself
smashing that space bar far more often
than i should have had to to skip
cutscenes
and i'm someone who cares about the
story i'm not saying i hated on the
dialogue of the cutscenes
they gave further personality to some of
the characters within the game
but they followed the same typical
cheesy flow that we've seen time and
time again
plus i think i've been a little bit
spoiled by the beautiful graphics that
ubisoft titles have shown me over the
years
however the redeeming feature that
outriders has to offer
is the journal entries these extra bits
of data can be found throughout the map
to give further explanation behind
certain events characters
and history behind the game again if we
refer back to that completely made up
figure of 30
of the player base actually being
interested in the story probably only 10
of that would bother collecting that
intel spread throughout the game and
piecing it together
titles like the division and destiny to
a greater extent
use this method to really flesh out the
story and bring depth to the respective
universes
without hindering the flow of the game
yet
if you listen to the general noise out
in the gaming community both of these
titles have absolutely no story behind
them
so what it looks like is outriders has
tried to include
both cutscenes and intel to be collected
separating and annoying that fictional
70 of players who really don't care
admittedly i haven't read through all of
the journals yet
and they may not offer much at all even
if they did we have no idea what the
full game will bring
but i can tell you from my position
alone these have been more interested in
the story than anything else
these are the pieces that add depth and
speculation the bits that truly immerse
me into the world
i'm not making this video to tell you
whether or not to buy it
in fact if you want to pre-order go
ahead it's your money
i'm sick of people telling gamers what
to do with their money and i will
happily delete any comments on this
video that push this
what i would like to strongly advise is
based purely on the number of people
who have come over from the division
destiny and even warframe
this isn't a live service game and it
has never been portrayed as open world
credit to the developers and how open
they've been they've been honest from
the start
you should expect 35 hours from the
story mode not including the side
activities
and the end game consists of something
they call expeditions
i'm not saying that i'll be able to
invest thousands of hours into this game
because it was never intended to be
played that way
[Music]
as i said earlier outriders doesn't
bring anything new and exciting to the
looter shooter genre
it's taken many aspects from titles i
mentioned earlier and produced something
that
for lack of a better word is is fun
there are a lot of things i'd like to
see improved on like combat
in solo situations it seems to be over
and done far too quickly
in co-op battles they're a little better
but will we see more epic battles
the map i know it to expect far more
variety in the full game
but the layout itself could use a bit of
work you can move into an area and
immediately know that enemies are about
to ambush you based on the layout of the
terrain alone
and i won't even talk about the motion
blur they've already said they'll be
addressing this
in summary i will be purchasing this
game i like what i've seen so far
and after this demo i have a good
understanding of what to expect
is it perfect oh god no but it provides
what i want
out of my gaming experience to be
entertained
thank you very much for watching i hope
you've enjoyed this quick recap of my
thoughts and first impressions around
outriders and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Music]
you